for those people sandra who are coming  into the labor force brand fresh  uh not old-timers who've been around for  a while the poor the minorities are  disenfranchised  uh those with less education young  people who haven't had the job  experience  these people aren't worth 15 an hour in  most cases  so understand he's not listing a  combination of traits he's not saying  you know  people who are poor and disenfranchised  and less educated  who are disproportionately minorities in  the country because of these historical  reasons  that would be bad enough to say they're  not worth fifteen dollars an hour he's  just saying  people from groups like these people  like the young aren't worth fifteen  dollars an hour  people like the uneducated aren't worth  fifteen dollars an hour people like  minorities aren't worth 15  an hour it's a total mask off moment for  this guy